was George Floyd murdered yes what Derek
Chauvin did to him was utterly
unnecessary I mean George Floyd was very
intoxicated he was acting up I find it
very difficult to see from the videos
whether or not he was resisting arrest
if anything he seems to have been in a
passive sort of what he needed to be put
into a police car and taken somewhere
and you know disciplined find or
something for somebody to put you know
the knee on his neck and he's pleading
for his life yeah I would call that of
murder and I'm not one for extreme
rhetoric what I think needs to be
brought into it though is that Tony
timppa was murdered four years before
with a knee into his back with the same
pleading for his life equally
unjustified recorded the cops got off
same thing and Timbo was white we're not
supposed to talk about that and of
course more white men are murdered that
way than black men and sometimes women
you're supposed to talk about the fact
that black people are killed by cops
disproportionately to our numbers in the
population but then again you can also
say that poverty makes you more likely
to encounter the cops and black people
are disproportionately likely to be poor
for unpardonable reasons that like we're
talking about there are larger issues
here that people are justifiably upset
about too many black people are poor but
as it turns out it's almost in the
numbers on this are almost cosmically
consonant in that there are black people
are 2.5 times more likely to be poor and
2.5 times more likely to be killed by
cops I don't think that's an accident no
I didn't make up those figures so what
that means is that one may despise the
cops but to say that George Floyd was
murdered because he was black as
tempting as it is to think that given
that that's the film that we're gonna
see again and again and again it's very
tempting
think that it's not an accurate
depiction of what actually happens and
we're in a technological moment where
it's really easy to see the larger
picture the Washington Post has done a
project that tells you exactly who's
been killed year by year by year and
under exactly which conditions at the
push of a button you could have done
that 10 years ago and yet we're being
foisted with a certain error so yes I
would say that George
Floyd was murdered but the problem is
that to say that it was because of his
black skin did tracks from solutions to
America's problems that would float all
boats to use a metaphor that's gone kind
of stain and what worries me about all
of this is that as I've written often
we're dealing not with the political
ideology but with something that an
anthropologist would recognize as
religion and it's easy to hear me say
that and think that I'm trying to make a
rhetorical point I don't mean like a
religion it is a religion the way that
you understand how these people operate
is to actually imagine how you would
interact with a Mormon who you were
trying to convince that Joseph Smith
didn't dig up tablets in the backyard
and again not rhetoric folks exactly
that it's the same frame of much it's
just that our language doesn't happen to
apply the label religion to the kinds of
ideology that we've seen over about the
past 10 years and so the problem is that
the tenets of this religion that
dominates is that to be against racism
trumped literally everything else there
are ranked priorities and being against
racism and we have to talk about what
that is but being against racism is
everything to the point that you allow
yourself not to make any logical sense
and so you must be against racism and so
the George Floyd must have been murdered
because he was black and there's no
questions asked and you cannot have any
kind of dialogue with a person of color
about racism if you have any kind of
dialogue with them if you question
anything that they say such as you do
you are a racist and they're no
questions to be asked and I've seen that
even in my own academic work
where you know as a much more naive
person I've tried to be an empiricist
about things and been savaged and not
quite understood it until nowadays I
realized wait a minute I was dealing
with parishioners it was the proto
versions of these things late 90s the
Oakland School Board tries to address
black kids lagging rates of scholastic
performance by treating black English as
a different language and bringing in
translation exercises and dialect books
there's very little evidence that that
sort of thing works and an awful lot of
evidence that certain kinds of you know
race neutral reading pedagogy techniques
really do help poor kids from bookless
homes ie for black kids I tried to talk
about that kind of thing and I was
ripped a new one by countless black and
white linguists and educators and I'd
say but look what you're proposing
doesn't work as well as other things
like English is not a separate language
nobody thought that back when Black
English was a lot less like standard
English than it is now I realized now
who's the religion it's not that this
religion emerged somewhere in nineteen
2013 I wasn't prioritizing anti racism
you talk about my Creole languages
Creole languages are fascinating because
what happens is that language is broken
down into a pigeon which is not a
language at all and then it's built back
up into a brand new language out of what
ones who are fragments that's really
neat there's a strain in Creole studies
and it's exactly what what we're talking
about that insists that Creole languages
didn't come from pigeons because pigeons
are not real language Creole languages
are just mixtures and it has nothing to
do with anybody ever having started with
a pidgin and the thing is every language
in the world is a mixture Creoles are
different from just mixed languages it
would be like claiming that um every
single creature in the world the analogy
is gonna go off the rails is some kind
of hybrid and so it's it's as if lynn
margulis was right about everything
everything is about combination there's
no such thing as there having been
really simpler creatures in the
Precambrian the idea is that the I'm
going to throw something up the
Ediacaran creatures are as
flex as Jaguars and people there's just
there's no difference that's what's
going on in Creole studies and if you
insist it no these are languages that
are born again it's like sea monkeys for
us I look like that they've built out of
little eggs and they come again you're a
racist and yes that's been aimed at me
and of course they're about three and a
half people in Creole studies who insist
on this loudly and explicitly almost
everybody else in the field doesn't want
to get mauled by them and so they decide
that they're agnostic about the matter
they say I don't really care how Creole
languages form as if that isn't the
fundamental thing that you wish to know
when you're studying languages where do
they come from and how are they born
it's like a biologist saying oh I don't
care about the DNA I don't care how
walruses are related to salamanders I
don't I'm agnostic about that I have
other things to do
that passes for actual coherent thought
in linguistics in my little area of
linguistics because you don't want to
say that black people ever didn't learn
a language well even if they were slaves
on a plantation where no one taught it
do them because of anti racism that's
what we're up against oh I see what you
mean that it can take over everything
but I always thought okay it's not just
college students it's also college
professors it's certain college town
realms but it's not gonna take over the
world
maybe I've been naive well I again agree
with a ton of what you say this is a
religion we are seeing exactly what
you're talking about in biology as well
we're having a fight over whether sex is
real that is absurd because this
couldn't possibly be clearer right yeah
I know it's happening everywhere so that
tells you how insidious it is because
almost everybody in my field knows
better and yet most are quiet or they're
hedging because they don't want to get
Mol or the mob right so but here's the
problem I have believed that George
Floyd was murdered I don't think that's
necessarily what happened at this point
and I think the problem is that that is
taking on religious momentum and so if I
can if you'll give me the opportunity to
scare you a little bit that's okay let
me paint a different picture I would
love to know yeah okay
what I saw on video what I know that I
saw is a miscarriage of justice a
massive one what I don't know is enough
about policing about drugs and
physiology about heart attacks to know
exactly what I saw I certainly don't
know that what I saw was racist for
exactly the Tony timba point that you
make that you know what we saw was that
the video was running on a case that
matches people's priors and so it got
broadcast and caught on and that was
about race but we don't know whether you
know let's say that Derek Chauvin did
murder George Floyd we don't know if it
would have been equally likely had he
been a white guy you can't know but
here's the thing that troubles me even
more at this point is there is reason to
believe that that George Floyd saying
that he could not breathe was occurring
before he was ever on the ground and
that he was having a heart attack
there's some evidence to this effect we
know from his autopsy that there were a
very potent combination of drugs in his
system
Faton all I believe methamphetamine we
know that the technique that Derek
Chauvin was using is a technique that is
officially sanctioned under some
circumstances and I think we know that
there was a discussion about whether or
not George Floyd was in a state and I've
now forgotten I can almost remember the
acronym for the state II XDS maybe that
required some kind of restraint to
prevent him from injuring himself or
others so here's the question it is
possible that what happened there as
egregious as it was fit with police
policy that the police policy is what is
in error and it is the police policy
that caused the miscarriage of justice
and while it's hard for me to imagine
that Derek Chauvin is a good guy because
he's obviously callous enough to have
ignored this man's pleading and
insistence that he couldn't breathe to
the point so he had a record of
being a very callous policeman before
but anyway right right so there's
evidence of that so this about what I'm
what I'm really getting at is our system
absolutely depends on the fact that we
do not convict people unless there has
been due process and yet we are now
speaking about Derek Chauvin as if we
all know that a murder took place and
that's certainly something you could see
something on video that would tell you
almost beyond a reasonable doubt that
somebody had been murdered but I don't
think what we saw on video tells us that
because there's too much stuff that most
of us don't know anything about like how
do these drugs affect you what is the
police policy in Minneapolis we don't
know any of those facts so so anyway
here's my concern is it possible for
Derek children to get a fair trial
in in the modern era at this arm not in
the public sphere like I think that it's
quite possible and possibly to possible
that he get off because of not only the
facts of the case but certain things
entrenched in the cops and the unions
and how trial works he could get off
because a very small number of people
look at the sorts of things you're
looking at and realize that he does not
deserve to be called a murderer
if English had a more explicit
subjunctive I'd use it there that he did
not deserve maybe he did but maybe he
didn't I'm not remotely offended at your
saying that maybe he didn't we don't
know like I'll even give you something
watching the tape there are two things
that strike me and one is that the Asian
one whose name I forget is just sitting
there watching and what we're supposed
to think is that he's this barbarian but
how many barbarians like that are there
who really would just stand there and
I've been told a part of it is that he
actually is essentially a trainee at
that point and he's supposed to be
different but still if somebody is down
there expiring on the basis of a clearly
murderous mood would he really be just
standing there and he
been giving an insouciant look into a
cellphone camera I've wondered and also
you're not supposed to say this and I've
never watched somebody die I don't know
but it's my intuition and I've had a few
other people secretly write to me but
they wonder he doesn't sound like he's
asphyxiated he keeps on saying I can't
breathe
but it's so clear it's so loud he keeps
saying oh man now I don't I've never
heard anybody it's fix e8 I may be
really missing something but you imagine
some sort of constriction and from the
sound the first time I heard this before
I knew it was gonna be a big deal I
thought it's terrible that he died but
when he's saying I can't breathe I hate
to admit it but it almost sounded like a
quote it's almost like he was he
remembered what Eric garner said and I'm
not saying that he's he's trying to do a
show or that he was happy but he doesn't
sound like he can't breathe now I say
that out of naivete I have never had my
knee on anybody's neck nobody's afraid
of their knee on mine but I am open I'm
wondering whether the death was due not
only to that pressure but to the fact
that he had other things inside of him
he couldn't have been a healthy man
based on what we've heard and he doesn't
deserve it but can you get a fair trial
in society no and so for what we'll see
based on the anti-racist imperative is
that he absolutely has to be guilty and
so for example Darren Walker and Mike
Brown the facts make it clear including
the black people who watch this who
often recanted their original testimony
which they made because they were afraid
of being jumped by the narrative but he
killed Mike Brown because Mike Brown
kept coming at him and he was afraid now
you can have a whole discussion about
why he couldn't have shot him in the
knee etc you hear that the cops are
trained to shoot to kill after a certain
point we don't the territory that again
I don't really have my bearing in but he
didn't just shoot the guy with his hands
up it isn't true and yet you know
there's a The New Yorker does a profile
of Darren Walker that makes him sound
like the devil spawn anyway because he
doesn't know the narrative 101 and so
you know he's what we must get rid of
and then today anybody who admits that
Mike Brown wasn't killed that way and a
lot of people just like to pretend
John for the legend is printed on some
level that happened you just know
there's gonna be a film we're at the
point where Mike Brown is shot
everything goes into blurry and there
strobe lights and their various
perspectives and all of a sudden it's
gonna be Rashomon as if there are many
different perspectives and the director
was gonna give interviews saying they
wanted to give everybody their say it's
not gonna just show what happened and
that's symbolic of the consciousness but
also nowadays you deflect so if you
don't want to talk about the Mike Brown
facts you talk about the fact that he
was laying on the street for four hours
and that's unjust I've heard people wax
eloquent about that to the degree that
people were talking about his supposedly
dying with his hands up six years ago no
so that we'll never be able to raise his
head in public again it's the same thing
with George Zimmerman Zimmerman's story
is quite different from what we were
told and yet his life is ruined because
these people are needed as symbols in
this narrative they are they're Judas's
and this is the kind of thinking that
we're encouraged to do this is to watch
this with people who otherwise think
normally and empirically it's a
religious frame of mind this is exactly
what I'm worried about so you say that
he will never get a fair trial in the
court of public opinion which I agree I
also don't think he can get a fair trial
in a courtroom at this point because
given the way we are all connected it
will be I think impossible to find a
jury that will not be aware that a
verdict that does not reflect public
opinion in this case will result in an
eruption of anger that yeah I mean it's
it's Rodney King times a thousand
and so here's the reason I find this so
terrifying is that I believe some kind
of possibly unprecedented trolley
problem is unfolding in this case and
that everybody will quietly calculate to
themselves maybe not even in their
conscious mind but someone
that in fact irrespective of what the
facts are in the case and you know let's
say that George Floyd had a heart attack
was highly likely to die and that the
knee on the neck as egregious as it was
it was a minor factor in his death right
that would obviously be a very important
fact in a case were this not racially
charged and were there no protests in
the streets but if the system concludes
that it must convict him then this
effectively is us participating in a
witch-hunt now I'm not saying that he's
not guilty of murder I think it's likely
he is guilty of murder but I don't know
that he's guilty of murder yet and my
sense is that we have already marked so
far down this road we are already now
speaking as if we can all agree that
he's guilty of murder here the doubt
exists where the question of race is
that we are unwittingly participating in
a dangerous religious exercise even
those of us who wish to resist doing
that at all costs you know what's
alarming there is that what you're
saying is that this is going to go
beyond people being unable to get
justice in the rarefied world of the
college campus where one wonders whether
that could change within our lifetimes
but it's going to be in actual courts of
law about matters having to do with
physical life and death and yes that's
alarming especially because you know
there is this critical race Theory
within legal theory the idea being that
we think not always of individuals but
of general stories and as pretty as that
sounds that's the sort of thing that
leads to the idea that even if on some
technical level this could even you
could even think of it as
philosophically profound on some
technical level if it turns out that so
van did not kill George Floyd if it does
that he did on some other level on some
narrative level because this has been
happening to us forever
and although most of the people on that
hypothetical jury probably don't read
critical race theory that way of
thinking is percolating into the general
consciousness and what might be alarming
is that it's no longer just people with
PhDs and the
it's beginning not to be just people who
read The New Yorker and listen to NPR
it's beginning to just be folks that is
um that is alarming if that is where
we're going and the verdict on Chauvin I
don't know that they say show then and
show that I'm gonna say show one Chauvin
could be seen as a bellwether of that
yes that that is true that this time he
doesn't get off despite the fact that
the facts are muddy and that even
civilians like us can see yeah that is
alarming and so then what happens breath
where are we going oh my goodness I'm
afraid if we are not very careful that
we are staring at the uninvented of the
Republic and I'm not sure that that that
idea that thought that possibility
properly horrifies people because as
flawed as this Republic is it's uninvent
is going to be an absolute disaster and
I think frankly this is something that
is more easily seen by people outside
the US and I've had contact with quite a
number who are frightened at what they
are seeing unfold even though they know
our system is unfair but the prospect of
the u.s. failing is is a dangerous one
for the world so there's a lot riding on
this as to your point about what is
potentially going to unfold in
courtrooms given the rhetoric and given
how aggressive the campaign is that is
causing people to adopt this critical
race theory now most of them don't know
that that's what they're adopting and I
should also say everything that you know
right you're just you're active in it
and you don't know where it came from or
what it actually means I also should say
my understanding is the critical race
theory was born as an honorable
investigation of biases inside
courtrooms and then it sort of morphed
into this monster but but in any case
I'm concerned that we are actually much
closer to the the place that you suggest
we might be headed with respect to
courtrooms because
in light of the beliefs that are being
now commonly expressed without the
ability to disagree with them there is
certain to be a two-tiered expression of
due process in a courtroom in other
words those who are understood to be
suffering from a history of oppression
will experience a bias in their favor
and those who were understood to be part
of the race that has been perpetrating
the oppression will face a very
different standard now the really
difficult part about this is that there
is some truth to the fact that the
reverse of that situation has existed in
courts since the Republic was founded
right so black people have had a raw
deal not only economically for reasons
I'd love to get back to if there's time
and if not this time we'll do it in a
future conversation but the system has
been unfair and it has been two-tiered
but we are actually now involved in a
public discussion in which instead of
ending oppression which has been the the
goal since the civil rights movement we
are actually talking about turning the
tables of oppression turning the tables
and creating the inversion of the values
that the nation is founded on and that
is a very dangerous idea it is it is
bound to be unstable and we will all
suffer from it
[Music]